>> Will Sentance: Nhưng còn một chút nữa.
Nếu chúng tôi đang điền, như Peter nói,
thuộc tính giá trị đó với dữ liệu từ Twitter, chuỗi hi,
thì chúng tôi muốn có thể sử dụng nó theo một cách nào đó, hiển thị nó, tận dụng nó.
Mark, bạn có thể giúp tôi không?
Nếu tôi biết rằng khi thuộc tính giá trị đó được cập nhật,
nó sẽ tự động chạy bất kỳ chức năng nào trong mảng chưa thực hiện này.
Làm cách nào để đưa một hàm vào mảng ẩn chưa thực hiện này?
Tôi được đưa ra phương pháp nào để đưa một hàm vào mảng chưa thực hiện đó, Mark?
>> nam ngoài màn hình: .then >> Will Sentance: .then, phương thức then.
Hoàn toàn chính xác.
Lời hứa về nó được JavaScript thiết kế để tự động kích hoạt
các hàm trong mảng này sẽ chạy với giá trị này làm đầu vào của nó
khi giá trị đó được JavaScript cập nhật tự động, bạn nhé.
Vì vậy, chúng ta hãy thực hiện phần đính kèm đó ngay bây giờ.
FutureData. sau đó, chúng tôi chuyển toàn bộ tham chiếu,
chúng tôi sẽ liên kết đến toàn bộ chức năng hiển thị.
Đây rồi, toàn bộ chức năng hiển thị.
Chúng tôi sẽ lấy nó và cất vào, tôi có nên viết một dòng ở đây không?
Và lấy nó và cất vào, tôi biết mình sẽ làm gì.
Sẽ lấy nó và lưu trữ nó vào, vì vậy dữ liệu trong tương lai là đối tượng màu hồng này ở đây.
Chúng tôi sẽ lấy nó và lưu trữ nó vào mảng chưa được thực hiện, trong đối tượng hứa hẹn đó.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi sẽ lấy màn hình hiển thị và [SOUND] bằng cách sử dụng hiệu ứng âm thanh, phải không?
Trong đó đi vào mảng chưa thực hiện, nó có.
Chức năng hiển thị.
Vì vậy, điều đó có nghĩa là khi công việc nền hoàn thành,
thuộc tính giá trị được cập nhật, nó sẽ tự động kích hoạt hiển thị
để chạy, trong đó đầu vào của màn hình được trả về hoặc
đối tượng phản hồi sẽ chỉ là Tweet đó, chuỗi hi.
Và nó sẽ lấp đầy bởi vẻ ngoài của nó vào màn hình,
họ có một thông số nhỏ đang chờ.
Dữ liệu có thể được điền bằng chuỗi hi, đối số.
Rất đẹp.
[SOUND] Tốt, chúng tôi đã thiết lập hai phần công việc nền.
Một trong số chúng đã hoàn thành và được đưa vào hàng đợi, chức năng liên quan,
sẵn sàng để chạy.
Tôi chắc rằng nó sẽ chạy ngay bây giờ.
Khi chúng ta bắt đầu ở mức 2 mili giây,
chúng ta sẽ thực thi chức năng nào?
Jason, ở thời điểm 2 mili giây, chúng tôi vừa hoàn thành FutureDays. Sau đó,
chúng ta sẽ chạy chức năng nào với tốc độ 2 mili giây, Jason?
>> nam ngoài màn hình: Chúng tôi sẽ chạy màn hình hoặc giả sử chúng tôi là một dòng bên dưới,
BlockFor300ms.
>> Will Sentance: BlockFor300ms, anh ấy đã đúng.
Đây rồi, BlockFor300ms.
Thương hiệu mới.
[LAUGH] >> Người nói 3: Bối cảnh thực thi.
>> Will Sentance: Người đẹp, chính xác!
Bối cảnh thực thi hoàn toàn mới để chạy BlockFor300ms.
Nó đang diễn ra trên ngăn xếp cuộc gọi của chúng tôi, chúng tôi sẽ xem xét mọi người,
sẽ rất vui nếu xóa nó trong giây lát.
BlockFor300ms, chúng tôi bắt đầu.
Và, khi chúng ta bắt đầu, nó sẽ thêm 300 mili giây, nhưng bạn sẽ không tin.
Khi chúng tôi ở trong đó, bạn sẽ không tin những gì xảy ra ở đây.
Tin vui mọi người.
Tin tốt.
>> Will Sentance: Người bạn thân yêu của chúng tôi từ Twitter đã trở lại và
cho biết ở khoảng 270 mili giây, này, tôi có tweet.
Tôi có tweet và ở 270 mili giây, nó đây, nó đã hoàn thành.
Và chúng ta mang lại những gì?
Tweet của chúng tôi là gì, Peter?
>> nam ngoài màn hình: Chuỗi hi.
>> Will Sentance: Chuỗi hi, tất nhiên là như vậy.
Đây rồi, chuỗi hi.
Được rồi, bây giờ, mọi thứ trở nên thú vị.
Khi chào trả lại hoặc nhận được phản hồi từ việc nói chuyện với Internet,
Mark, việc hoàn thành gì sẽ xảy ra?
>> nam ngoài màn hình: FutureData.value.
>> Will Sentance: Chính xác thì nó sẽ là [CROSSTALK],
cái nào sẽ kích hoạt, Kayla, chức năng nào để chạy trên ngăn xếp cuộc gọi?
Không.
>> nữ ngoài màn ảnh: Không, trên hàng đợi.
>> Will Sentance: Nghe có vẻ hợp lý, đó chắc chắn là một dấu hiệu.
>> [LAUGH] >> Will Sentance: Điều chúng tôi chắc chắn là
nó không đi thẳng vào ngăn xếp cuộc gọi, không thể nào.
Không có cách nào có thể, đúng không, vì chúng tôi đã có BlockFor300ms ngay tại đó.
Bây giờ chúng ta đang ở gần đại khái, nó sẽ là gì?
Chúng tôi đang ở gần, tôi không biết, nó là gì, 270 mili giây ở đây, hoặc
một cái gì đó xung quanh.
Đó là thời điểm mà chúng ta đang ở ngay bây giờ.
Chờ đã, chúng tôi không thể đột ngột ném màn hình vào ngăn xếp cuộc gọi.
Vì vậy, bây giờ chúng ta hãy lưu ý, có, chính xác.
Vào hàng đợi gọi lại, nó sẽ đi.
Tôi chắc rằng điều đó phải chính xác.
Điều đó nghe rất hợp lý.
Và đó là 270 mili giây.
Được rồi, BlockFor300ms tiếp tục chạy.
Chúng tôi thoát ra, và mọi người sẽ như thế nào,
Đại khái là 302 mili giây.
Có lẽ, chính xác, đại khái, bất cứ điều gì.
302 mili giây, hãy loại bỏ điều này khỏi ngăn xếp cuộc gọi.
Hãy lấy BlockFor300ms ra khỏi ngăn xếp cuộc gọi.
Nhân tiện, mọi người đều rất tốt cho đến nay,
không có gì chúng ta chưa từng thấy trước đây ở 302 mili giây.
printHello đã ngồi đó đợi đúng 302 mili giây.
Tôi cho rằng bây giờ nó được phép chạy, phải không?
>> nam ngoài màn ảnh: Không.
>> Will Sentance: Không?
Điều này thật điên rồ, vậy điều gì sẽ xảy ra vào thời điểm này, Brayden?
>> nam ngoài màn hình: Cái tôi đầu tiên, trên màn hình.
[LAUGH] >> Will Sentance: Tôi thấy não
nhạy cảm ngay bây giờ.
Chắc chắn bảng điều khiển sẽ đăng nhập cho tôi đầu tiên vào thời điểm này, đúng vậy.
Vì vậy, tôi là người đầu tiên., Chúng tôi biết rằng mã không đồng bộ của chúng tôi sẽ được ưu tiên.
Chúng tôi có thể làm một triệu trong số đó, luôn ưu tiên.
Vì vậy, ở 302 mili giây, chúng tôi nhận được tôi đầu tiên.
Đó là nó, đúng, ở 302 mili giây,
chúng tôi nhận được console.log (Tôi là người đầu tiên!).
Bây giờ, mọi thứ trở nên thú vị.